taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey welcome to taste buds the podcast
about food we fight it out we duke it
out
we argue food my name's joe hey i'm sal
we got a good one for you today
oh we got a good one for your taste
buddies we have we have sort of uh
traipsed into
breakfast territory in the past uh not
not i guess less frequently than some of
the other meals but uh we today
are daring to set foot in the arena of
cereal breakfast cereal uh and we got
two goodins
that are gonna face off here uh a
classic
you want to get something out of the way
that we both think this is uh
sometimes we have you know we also yes
we also bond over that's a good point
yeah
yeah we think the best breakfast cereal
ever is captain crunch crunch berries
at the moment uh you know yeah
it fluctuates but they're always a
competitor for me and there's one that i
love one of my favorite skills that i
love
that has recently changed their formula
formula or or flavor
that has taken a hit for me but in its
best form i put it up there and it's
never anyone's favorite right posts
alphabets
but i could never put that up against a
popular cereal
you know man i had alphabets once as a
kid or twice maybe i remember it
it just tasting like it was like it was
missing it was like lucky charms except
there was no marshmallows
that's right it's a little different but
it's right and sometimes i think the
marshmallows are a bit too much but they
did venture in
uh alphabets was a blue box alphabets
with marshmallows was their purple box
and it was just as popular if not more
popular
i don't know if they still make up the
alphabets with marshmallows okay
but uh but that's not who i'm gonna put
up against because
i know for a fact i'm gonna lose that
one by a landslide and it's just i kind
of want
well i could argue it believe me but but
but i'd rather do something that i think
is a little bit of a closer race
i'm also a huge fan big surprise of
chips ahoy cereal
yeah which i didn't bring into the fall
this this company has got you
by by the the the ball the balls
that's what you want to call them but i
will be arguing
on behalf of an american classic and i
don't like chocolate cereal
by the way i don't understand i don't
understand i don't want to wake up
and eat sweets like i mean well i guess
i should
i don't want to wake up and eat
chocolate it's it's weird to me i i
don't i don't want chocolate the moment
i wake up i don't want chocolate
i don't want chocolate you don't like
cocoa pebbles i do not
you don't like chips or uh i mean a
cookie crisp
well when i said i didn't like chocolate
cereal
i didn't mean besides these ten i know
i'm just
i'm so getting you ready buddy i don't
like um
i hate pancake or waffle mapley syrup
cereal or
i don't like it when they just load all
like this it's like supposed to taste
like something else
do you like chocolate chip pancakes oh
you sure dynamite
really yeah but there's something about
those that i don't know i don't feel it
as
chocolate per se blueberry i'll take
first but my point is in serial form i
don't want to be chomping on some
processed chocolate i hate chocolate
chips flakes
i hate chocolate chip pancakes it's too
much
it's too much oh my god
what what well you just see just eat one
this way you curb it
no no no but those first few bites so
forget about it they blow your bees off
i like it
i don't like it because you can't your
bees aren't blown off
first three bites of a chocolate chip
pancake nope and i'll tell you why and
it's the same reason i'm not crazy about
blueberry pancakes either
now i'll take a blueberry pancake over
chocolate and once in a while
i'll think i want a blueberry pancake
and then i'll regret it
i never want a chocolate pancake uh now
here's why
another episode just pouring that syrup
onto it
it's too much man it's too diff it's two
different kinds of sweets
i don't know why i agree i don't even
pour syrup onto it i pour my syrup on
the side
and i control my uh my sear of
proportions
but i dip into the syrup sometimes i
don't even do that you know what i do
because that's too much you know what i
do
sometimes i place my fork into the syrup
i lift it out
i let it drip off so that there's just a
light coating on the four
prongs and then i spear the pancake
and i eat it with as minimal maple syrup
as possible i get a touch of flavor
but i i hate dousing it in a lot of
syrup okay
so if i've enlightened you in any way
please take that no i still don't want
to eat chocolate chip pancakes
um it's sorry i think a waffle is better
than the pancake anyway
i mean what do you do with this i mean
it's ridiculous
the international house of waffles yeah
that's a that's a popular
that's what you should stand behind
stand behind ihop they're known for
quality
there's nothing inside
you know they're accessible they're very
accessible
like like like there is
accessible establishments that i don't
think are known
for high quality fresh ingredients you
know if i if i'm going to
i could name a i could name a hundred
other places that will give me a better
pancake
than ihop a hundred change no major
change
my point is it's chain food chain food
correct yeah you know any other chains
that's putting five shirts out
on the table perkins perkins
get the f out of here
well i mean i don't get any credit for
answering correctly
perkins does not put perkins is the ihop
of perkins
perkins is the ihop of ihop like perkins
i'm not going to say they don't what am
i trying to say
perkins is the ihop of non-ihop ihops
listen i have ali simple i'll eat at
perkins but
you're you're putting apples and oranges
together here perkins is not
perkins is fine it's identical menus
denny's denny's putting out serps
scissors like nobody's business they are
not like nobody's business they don't
have that
they do not have that syrup bar on the
table like ihop does
about that don't get me wrong see what i
say i don't know about it but i'm
but i do feel that denny's perkins and
ihop are cut from the same cloth and so
and i do know that they i think they
might have multiple don't get me wrong
no one's going to put the stamp on a
pancake
like the chain of international house of
pancakes lest we
lest we call out when they change their
names to international house of
that was a joke burgers or whatever it
was a publicity joke oh it did well
it did you're talking about it that's
the point i thought they changed that's
what everybody thought and they didn't
so they're
i mean this is brand confusion no they
said they they did it it was a thing to
just let you know that we have burgers
now and it was a big publicity stuff
i thought they only had burgers now and
not pancakes and i've never gone in one
again
because i could get a burger you haven't
noticed the signs are changed back to
ihop
they changed all the signs yes that was
awesome that's a bit i guarantee you
someone got fired for that i guarantee
it
no it worked like a charm oh that was a
faux pas
it wasn't a faux pas like a charm that
was that was taken
you know decades of loyal of
of goodwill and and being like we we
we turn our let me get back to why a
blind eye
at the pancakes a flavored pancake is a
bad thing this isn't even the episode
it's not but we're going to talk about
it now
let me get back to why why don't we save
it for why don't we save that
because you know what that's what i
thought and then you had to put your
little jab in that you think the
wildfool is better than the pancake and
you knew what you were doing when you
did that
i'll go i'll change the waffle pancake
right now don't tell me with a good time
change it to waffle pancakes are you
serious are you serious because you
opened up a can of worms damn it
because i also believe that a good
episode could be pancake versus
nah you're right here's the thing you
opened up
pancake and waffle the proper adversary
to face off here
or or do we pull back a little
and pancake known as the king of
breakfast food really unless you're in
bavaria
does the pancake go up against like a
bacon egg and cheese no no no no we're
doing a two-parter
because that it's like the breakfast
type very different whereas
pancake is more popular than a waffle
and they also are kind of similar
i think waffles have a good shot and i'm
taking pancakes all day long
now here's what we should do we should
ask them if they want to see pancake or
swaffle
or pancake versus bacon egg and cheese
we should ask them that at least
you can't put a pancake versus a bacon
egg and cheese but then you're arguing
what's a better breakfast food
better breakfast food but but but you
because it's like our
arguing apple juice versus orange juice
what we did pancakes and waffles are the
adversaries george garland had a joke
i have a message here from the
international house of pancakes and it
says
waffles that was like like that they're
they are the face-off food does the
international house of pancakes serve
waffles i'm sure they do
not think you need to google it but
since i don't know please give me the
actual facts
and i'd like to say we should not only
do pancakes versus waffles right now
because
you stirred it up you started something
and you know what you did and don't roll
your eyes because you knew what you were
doing
because of my cereal so was i but you we
talked
you brought up pancakes being not as
good as possible
change it change it change it all right
he brought it up
folks you almost saw golden grahams
versus fruit we'll do it another time
it's coming back it's coming back but
you let us down a road
and we talked last night on the phone
about what are we doing tomorrow and we
brought
up waffles versus pancakes and you go
i'm waffles all the way and i go dude on
pancakes all the way
so we i you know here we are here's a
big one then if you want to change it on
the fly
and i guess check your local listings
for fruit loops first golden grahams
let's come in if you can't go anywhere
better breakfast is how i'm titling it
what gets put first better breakfast
food pancakes waffles
or pancakes second cause you think
pancakes is going to win
i think waffles could win i don't agree
with it but i do think it could win i
think and this is
what do i think the fans are seeing a
little behind the scenes right now
and i like that for them i think
pancakes is more popular
in general i like to put oh i won't even
give anything away bro
we got let's just just just i don't want
you people hearing the logic and then
thinking that you're gonna you people
very adversarial right out of the gate
buddies you taste buddy launch that poll
launch that pole and let's just get into
it dude
all right let's just get into it because
this is already getting hot
you know we had two real hot episodes
there already and i was like we don't i
don't know if we got a lot left in the
tank
i'm like we got a lot left in the tank
oh i got i got left in the house yeah
and by the way pancakes are waffles
which one do you think this is part one
of a two-parter on breakfast battles
okay mikey make a note of that the
breakfast battles
okay yeah this is part one part two is
the next episode it's bacon versus
sausage
and then i gotta we got to do cereal we
could do a whole breakfast month it's
breakfast month like shark week okay all
right
so so all right so i just want to know
and then you always roll your eyes to me
but what am i
listing first put waffles first since
you think the pancakes is going to win
i also want your opinion i don't want to
just bulldoze i've told you my opinion
three times now i've said put pancakes
second because you think it's gonna win
i think waffles i don't want you to just
just agree what i'm saying for the sake
of it i'm not i want to make sure you
get a fair shake of what you're paying
can i get a little
can you give me a little more credit
than that please you know when people
say them together
no one ever goes waffles and pancakes
people always say
pancakes and waffles so put pancakes
second with the and the yeah
but yeah
it also this is going to get regional
too
yeah because you got ihop everywhere i
need my belgian people to uh is it long
barbarian
belgian belgian launched better
breakfast food
waffles pancakes boom boom all right
we're in
it's out so let me say why now that the
clock is running now let me say why i
think this is so regional
it's not just about america and belgium
and these other places
it's within america there is an internal
struggle between these two foods
because you do have ihop which is a
nationwide restaurant
but you also have waffle house now
waffle house is not
oh man i like to you brought waffle
house into this
well waffle house is not as nationally
as nationally as accessible
because it's not as spread around but
people that like waffle house will live
and die on the sword of waffle house
so you're going to get a lot of i mean
you're going to get a lot of support
this is nothing against waffle house
but i didn't grow up around waffle
houses and i've only been to them a few
times
and uh i don't want to attach my
waffle to the waffle house chain you
could attach your pancake to whatever
chain you want
it's not attaching it to anything i'm
just saying it shows you the love for
the food
i don't know enough about waffle house
they make a hell of a waffle
it's called a waffle house i've never
had a waffle at a waffle house good
but my point is i'm arguing there's love
out there the waffle in every way that
you want it i'm oh i love those you know
what i as a kid
when my mom made um aunt jemima
blueberry waffles was my favorite
breakfast
i like them over egos i like my waffle
square not round
but then again i'll
i'll take eggos i'll take it goes as
well but my point is is that i love a
delicious
waffle in the house but then i love a
delicious waffle
at a diner and how it's bigger and
the the uh what do you call them what
should we call the cr nooks the crevices
the compartments the divots what do you
want to call them i call them the holes
personally well they're not holes are
they now
well that's what i call them i mean it's
not like a swish it means
you ask me what i call them i tell you
what i call them
okay well this is what okay so first of
all this is this is what general
consensus is how many people prefer
waffles or pancakes
in general 47 of people prefer pancakes
to waffles does that mean 53 is waffles
but among those for whom belly aches are
a bigger problem
than headaches 59 percent of
people i don't understand what's going
on here they're saying what kind of a
pole was that
pancakes are way older than waffles
they've been around for some time at
least
since the 19th sorry the 1430s i'm
competing with a dish
that has been around 690 years
first look the first wealth of water was
590 years first waffle iron was patented
in 1869.
oh my god so 400 439 years later
in comes the waffle now let me and it's
the pancakes adversary
that should say a lot about the waffle
and what it's done
stages to now the only waffle i'll eat
the only waffle elite
is a frozen waffle that's it
you don't want to freshly made waffle
out of a waffle iron on your local
holiday inn
no like a continental breakfast
you don't want to go to you don't want
to go to a diner i can't a new york
diner and order a belgian waffle i can't
tell
belgian waffle don't get me hold on you
don't want to you don't
have about you don't want to have a i'll
get to belgium hold on
a waffle in between some nice ice cream
no some
some fresh whipped cream no or ice cream
no not at all you ever heard of that
yeah hot waffle would ice cream it's
been disgusting my face i've heard of it
i don't like it
uh the only waffle you'll eat is a
frozen store-bought waffle yeah
and you're gonna argue that the pancake
is better than the waffle in its
fullest form i've eaten the other kinds
and i don't like it
i don't like the flavor of it i like the
flavor of a frozen waffle i find that
other waffles
as you call them homemade don't have the
same flavor they usually have a much
sweeter or nuttier flavor that i don't
care for
i like the flavor of a frozen waffle i
could crush a
box of eggos easily easily in one
sitting i could do it if
if if i if i was if i was in the mood
but you're right you're in good company
but
i can't tell you i've never once stopped
at that waffle iron
at the hot at the holiday inn not once
on a continental breakfast
that's wild because even the process
again i'm gonna hearken back
i love the overall experience of the
food that's how i judge it right
i love the waffle iron i love getting
the batter and watching it
fill up in the different holes until it
fills it up and then you
push the iron down it sizzles and then
there's a flip involved
and you get them golden brown and what
happens with a waffle is you get
crispy and doughy you get when you
spread the um
the syrup and the butter you get pockets
some have more than others
you get a different taste experience i'm
biting into a waffle i'm getting
something real
crisp on the outside then all of a
sudden it's getting chewy and fluffy and
inside
and i'm getting the creaminess of the
butter and the maple syrup
it's multiple textures combining for a
flavor experience
in my mouth that a pancake doesn't do a
pancake is light and fluffy
but the consistency is the same and a
lot of pancakes aren't made the right
way
and it just like ends up being this real
mushy maple syrup sponge
whereas the crispiness of the waffle
holds the maple syrup from penetrating
through to the inside dough and then
when you bite it you're still
getting them in a layer of syrup
crisp dough and not this just sponge
disc
in your mouth of pancakes i will say
this i cannot
i cannot take credit uh or
responsibility for the people that don't
know how to make the pancake properly
that's their problem but when a pancake
is made properly
it should have the consistency of moist
duncan hines cake basically that's where
you're at
except it's warm i love it in its
greatest in its greatest state
i'm telling you that the pancake is
floating it should be it should be thin
it should never be crispy or crunchy on
the outside it should be soft and spongy
to the touch
and it should be thin and when you cut a
pancake up made properly like that
into into little wedges and then i cut
it all up and then i butter it
so i get the butter all everywhere and
then i pour syrup on the side and i poke
and i dip
and that's how i eat it and it is great
i'm glad that's how you eat it
but why is it better than the waffle
because it's just a it's just a more
in my opinion it's a more wonderful they
sell frozen pancakes
yes uh well they are not popular and i
wonder why no well i mean but
you don't hear people getting frozen
pancakes like you hear people getting
frozen waffles no but my dad when i'm
home visiting for instance
perhaps this christmas he'll make me pay
ancient
greece in the morning he'll make me
pancakes in the morning he'll make all
of us pancakes in the morning
but my point is is there's nothing like
it
there's nothing like it there's the
pancakes of late night food you go to a
doctor
something very very like it's called the
waffle
and it's what we're debating and it's
why you said pancakes should go against
waffle
because it's it's rightful adversary
because they're so close together then
bacon isn't it let me tell you
so the waffle goes against it the waffle
has been around 440 years less
and is its contemporary competitor it's
done a lot you have a food that
was invented in the 1400s in ancient
greece the pancake
here's the other reason i like the
pancake you can make it in different
ways with different ingredients like if
you're on a low carb
thing i have a recipe where you can make
pancakes out of bananas and and
and almond flour and whatever and then
do that anything i've never been able to
do in a waffle
have you tried no have you ever searched
it nope have you ever seen anyone else
if they've done it no i've just made the
assumption that's right sounds like the
typical joe derosa argument uh but show
me
show me uh mike look up uh
all right look at those two photos can
you just go back a second if you could
throw those photos up look at the
waffles on the left of the pancakes all
right both look delicious again
i'm not i don't hate pancakes but if i
have to choose i'm choosing a waffle
every time
look at how those waffles they're just
so much more appealing to me
you got this stack of pancakes they're
smushing each other together the same
exact thing
you dump the syrup on the top if you're
not putting in the work to lift every
flapjack or every pancake
and put butter on everything and syrup
on everything then you're just getting a
big
the waffle it's like a leaning tower of
deliciousness
there's just they decided to put fruit
it doesn't have to even be butter they
put a little fruit on it
they put a little syrup on it yeah it's
crispy it's golden
you're comparing one picture versus one
picture
that i've seen pancakes i've seen
pancakes prepared like that with fruit
and whipped cream
you're right i'm comparing two pictures
but i will say look i don't care for it
honestly you don't get the texture
you're just eating a pile of sponges
when you when you're eating a pancake
that's the texture pancake that's
doesn't even
sound good to me oh and waffle sounds
good
waffle sounds intriguing it sounds
exotic waffle waffle what is that
it sounds like something that comes out
of your colon is what it sounds like it
doesn't sound right it sounds gross
it sounds great about what they did with
a waffle they they have waffle cones
right you don't have a pancake cone what
no you know what else i hate i hate a
waffle ice cream sandwich and you know
waffles can actually hold the ice cream
you know what else i've had that always
sounds like a great idea and then it
sucks
a waffle sandwich i've gone to
restaurants where it's like we put two
we put a piece of fried chicken in
between
slices of waffles oh my god oh my god
you're doing yourself a disservice i
never heard of the waffle sandwich but i
almost forgot
that you could put fried chicken with
waffles for one of the greatest meals
that anyone's ever heard of in your
entire
life i wasn't even gonna bring it up and
you go ahead and bring up
waffles and fried chicken you're not
doing yourself a disservice you can't
have a fried chicken
smushed between a bunch of soft pancakes
you don't think you could have some i
mean nobody does it but you don't think
you could have i mean i think it would
be
adjacent but there's a reason why the
dominating dish and the original dish
and the only dish you really see
is is fried chicken look at that pancake
sauce i mean just just google
i mean the pancake sandwich everything
from ross goes
by the way by the way before you get too
up on your high horse there
who's heard of a pancake sandwich i'm
sorry a
crepe a crepe a crepe is not a pancake
it's defined as being a part of the
pancake is a pancake a crepe is a crepe
i mean crepe is you are about to argue
that
that by extension you could tell me a
crepe is better than a waffle fluffy
swedish pancakes
buddy when you go let me ask you a
question crepes we know what we're
talking about
we know quickly a crepe is a pancake
that's
been thinned out so can we go to every
single episode ever that he's done
where he says you cannot adjust you
cannot lean
oh you gotta lean on the fact that you
have to serve it a different way
you i'm saying it's another version of
something can you contradict yourself
but i'm saying it's another version of
that
give a [ __ ] about the version of the
pancake call the crepe because that's a
creep
when i go get a crate i get a creep when
i want to creep back like a crate when i
want to mike
what we're arguing when you do the edit
i want it here
arguing i want to hear it on the wall
that is thin it doesn't taste the same
and it's not the same concept whatsoever
tastes
extraordinarily the same you just never
eat it
with syrup and butter are you ordering
crepe versus
you never have i mean what what we're
talking about the traditional pancake
joe you've never
you can't co-op the crepe and now make
the crate
it's gonna be 99 to one percent
important one counterpoint so let me get
this straight
you can do frozen waffle versus waffles
hold on you could do frozen waffles and
you could do frozen pancakes and you
brought a belgian waffle that's a
completely different version of the
waffle
it's so awful the size it's the same
thing
the crepe is just containers pancakes
the crepe does not if i if you close
your eyes and i put a crepe in your
mouth and i go
how do you like my pancakes you're gonna
go this ain't a pancake it's a grape no
that's what you're gonna do when you're
gonna stain highlights that's how your
voice is gonna go
it's not good i know you i would say
this is a thin pancake oh yes
they wanted they called them pancakes it
says it right in front of your face i'm
going to go to a little cafe and go
can i have an espresso and a little
pancake please let me ask you a question
when your facts come up on the internet
they're facts and when mine come up you
go they don't count
why are waffles better let's just
answer my question about the crepe why
when you see the factual information a
crepe is part of the pancake family it's
considered a thin pancake does that not
count as fact
as it does you so what you're
what you're telling me right now is
you're contending that crepes can be
as equal a part of this argument versus
waffles absolutely
oh my god when you're talking about
bringing you
changed the rules it's not a rule change
we can't get anywhere
thin pancakes and you use them to choose
when i say the word pancake does a crepe
come to mind no it did today
oh joe please it did so
if you say i'm starving i want to get
some pancakes
what are you saying and what do i think
you're getting okay fine if i'm at a
local
cafe and i say i'm gonna get a crepe and
a coffee
okay am i getting a stack of silver
dollar pancakes you know
have you ever gone to a crepe restaurant
people eat them with butter and syrup
like pancakes
they do that if you want to order if you
want to fight crape first of all if you
want to go to creepers
i'll delete i'll delete i don't i'll do
crate i'll leave it alone i'll do crate
first waffle right now
i'll do something that's unprecedented
i'll do crepe versus waffle
right now and give you
a ten percent no i'll give you ten i'll
give you a ten thousand dollars i'll
wave it around
i will give you a ten percent handicap
no you know what
i'll give you a 20 handicap give me a
break i will give you a twenty percent
handicap on crepe purse waffle
stop what the crash okay then you can't
count belgian waffles then
then you can't count belgium because
that's a bigger waffle so let's just say
for the sake of this pancake version
don't roll your eyes
at it if little pancakes don't count
giant waffles don't count
that's it but but the crepe is not the
same as a pancake it is
it just said on the screen it's a thin
pancake it just said it it's in theory
oh my god mike please go to the crepes
wikipedia page
it says it right there it's made on a
cast iron griddle it's a pancake that's
been
thinned out and stuffed it's thinner
belgian
waffle is still called a waffle
excuse me oh my gosh
grape is also the french name for a
pancake
all right well i don't call waffle
something else it's
french it means pancake but you're not
battling the preparation of a crate holy
[ __ ] you're battling the classic
holy [ __ ] you know what he does when he
wants me i put in classic ice cream
sandwich traditional ice cream sandwich
original blah blah blah when he doesn't
want me to he just puts
pancake and now traditional pancake is
out the window
if i would have wrote traditional
pancake versus traditional waffle would
that make you happier
guess what i mean i guess when i say
traditional waffle people
think about a diner belgian waffle just
to prove my point mike
just to prove my point showed that i'm a
fair sport more than fair wait wait
don't don't wait wait don't go off yet
let me read this
okay mike crepes are thinner and larger
than an english pancake
they usually have richer ingredients
including sugar and or cream and are
only cooked on one side okay okay so
i'm trying to do something to your
benefit hold on
you could argue that it's prepared
differently so technically it doesn't
count
i want you to show me now how a belgian
waffle is prepared same as a wrap versus
a regular waffle it's just bigger
it's the same thing when i say
traditional waffle people think oh the
waffle i get at the diner that's a
belgian waffle
belgian waffles are thicker and often
larger because they are made in a waffle
iron that has deeper grits
the belgian waffle is also made a little
differently than regular waffles
often with elite leavening agent or
egg whites used to make the batter light
and fluffy
it doesn't count it's out my point being
is that a belgian waffle is called a
waffle
you don't i mean that's ridiculous sal
that's ridiculous it's called something
different
like saying it's like saying a a a a a a
cabasi isn't part of the sausage family
because it's called a kabasi i mean
that's crazy
hold on if i come back for that diner
and i go and you go hey what'd you do
when i went to a diner what'd you eat i
ate a waffle
right you know what i'm talking about
yeah okay this that
that i ate a waffle that i come back you
know what i said you know what i say
ready you know what i say let's do it
ready hey son where were you just now
i know i got one no no no no no no no no
i'm gonna do the one we're doing i had
another one okay
wait to do it though ready okay okay
ready yeah where were you i was at my
local diner which would you have
today yeah oh i had a uh a waffle
just one because they're tiny just one
waffle
no the dino waffle's a big oh you had a
belgian waffle
yeah that's different well it's a waffle
yeah but it's different
hold on joe i just got back from the
diner and boy am i stuffed
right but i took it to go container okay
it's not clear it's
it's plastic you can't see what's in it
okay i had pancakes
great you want them yeah oh yeah open it
up boom it's four crepes what do you say
to me
these those aren't pancakes these look
like
you say i thought you said pancakes
sweetie this is a grape
that's what you would say you would not
open it and go jesus
delicious because when you lied to your
teeth people understand
you just seen you for the day that
you're
saying is this belgian waffle doesn't
hold up doesn't hold on babe hold on
ready joe how are you this morning great
guess where i just came from the crate
place the diner oh great you know what i
had
crepes i had waffles oh good i actually
have extra waffles here because i was so
hungry
here open it when you open it are you
going to go this is not a waffle
no you're going to go to my looking at
it oh [ __ ] i don't know what i'm looking
at you handed me an invisible thing
what am i looking at a belgian waffle a
belgian waffle i got
i don't like that no no no no no no no
that's my point
that's how i point that's not my point i
have
a to-go container it's it's it's opaque
you can't see through it is that what
it's called yes you can't see through it
i say joe you say sal what'd you eat
today i said i had waffles they were so
great i had so many i took some home
would you like some you say yes i hand
you it you open the to-go container that
you can't see inside until that moment
when you open it your brain will confirm
oh yeah those are the waffles he was
talking about and then you will eat the
waffles you will not go
this is not a waffle flip it reverse it
smack it down
bell bib devoe i'll tell you exactly how
i'll tell you right now i got i had a
step i had
to tell you exactly pancakes hand me the
crepes you're calling pancakes i'll show
you exactly how i had a stack of
pancakes
you you open it up it's it's two crepes
in there
you would go say pink no you go oh you
said pancakes
now you know what i would do show me
show me give me the key good
good morning to you too do you have some
breakfast yeah i hate breakfast we'll
talk to you
would you have pancakes yeah i had a lot
of them good can i see you so many i
can't eat anymore good you want
something that's weird
because they're so tiny and thick
let me look at him you want some of my
pancakes yes my pancakes
you know that's weird mike it's weird
that he calls them pancakes
traditionally people say these are
crepes but technically they are pancakes
sal
so good job your argument on a
technicality
his whole argument is based on a
technicality so you want to acknowledge
if crepes don't count then belgian
waffles don't count because belgian
waffles are also made differently i'm
hearing what you're saying and i'm
counter-pointing by saying if i told you
i went to the diner and had a waffle in
my
container i just had a stroke and you
opened it and it was a belgian waffle
you would go
as advertised if i did the same thing
you'd have to remark out loud you would
have to remarkably
well oh these are crepes i guess it's
like a pancake but i thought you meant
the other thing
and i'm basing my argument on that
okay i think it's stupid
it's like saying this it's like saying
this i feel like i'm i feel
like i'm saying i feel like i say my
thing i feel let me say my thing before
you say i feel like i'm
really irrational and you're just gonna
you just you're just gonna say it let me
say my thing
it's like saying salsa isn't a dip
because it's called salsa
and you go yeah because that's just what
they call it from where it comes from
it's it's a little more of a blurred
line
of a blurred line it is in the dip
because you haven't put something into
salsa
yes so i don't necessarily butter and
syrup on crepes for christ's sakes you
call me bastard
don't you don't yes you do you get some
type of uh
strawberry sometimes you do you get
hazelnut and bananas sometimes
i get ham and cheese in the middle of
the things you know what i never get
chocolate chips or blueberries thank you
if you saw pimp's face when you just
said that
again you just pulled you pulled the rug
out from your own
two silly feet why because
nobody eats a pancake with ham and
cheese there was a pretty sandwich there
was a pancake breakfast sandwich earlier
that i tried to point out to you but you
because you were so good at multitasking
you didn't notice it right because your
eyes were
yeah look at that look at that no you
can google
uh you can google you can google red
wing boot in between two pancakes i love
it and see it joey
google red wing boot in between two
pancakes
i hope it comes up
no sorry my point though my point though
look at that deliciousness my point
though look at that
that doesn't look amazing i'm not saying
it doesn't look good
i'm saying that that nobody goes to a
store and says i just
when a waitress comes over and goes hey
doll and she pulls a pencil out for her
behind her ear
and she goes like this and she goes to
write down she goes i have a stack of
pancakes she goes
sure would you like anything on that i
nev no one goes
of course ham and cheese
nobody says that to a regular
traditional pancake the fact that you
could be like i have ham and cheese on
my crepe
i said i can get it the crepe
is meant for something different than a
traditional pancake
it's a thinner pancake that's made
slightly differently
and if it doesn't count the need or does
the belgian waffle
joe's favorite pancakes okay joe's
favorite pizza are you gonna eat a
belgian waffle sandwich like you would
with regular waffles
you're gonna eat a belgian waffle no
you're not cause it's too big you can't
do it
what i don't even understand your
argument anymore you were bragging
earlier about how you could make a
belgian
or you could make a a waffle sandwich
and you could never do that with a
pancake
and i said yes you can you ever have a
crepe and you said crepes don't count
you're gonna make a belgian waffle
sandwich you're gonna take two belgian
waffles
joe that would be ridiculous because
they're this big but i would take a
triangle of it
and combine fold it over you know like a
slice of bread
oh okay
really all right let's go to the polls
hold on hold on hold on i don't know
let's just go just so you know joe's
favorite pancakes are ham and cheese
pancakes no i didn't say that yeah
that's not what i said
joe loved one of joe's favorite pancakes
is ham and cheese pancakes
you said you love to put it on them i
didn't say that you said the words i
love to put on him and i didn't say that
i'd love to have my crease with him and
he said i like cr yes
i didn't say it was my favorite pancake
you said butter and maple syrup
that's a traditional pancake bro okay
well guess what you said that
traditional watercolor
isn't five inches thick there you go but
it's still
just a waffle you're putting it still
just a pancake
it's a thin pancake times like these
that i wish we had a third party
holy [ __ ] you saw it on the internet
with your own two eyes
now i'm craving ham and cheese pancakes
all day and night i can't wait i can't
wait
i can't wait i said it looked delicious
when you saw the picture of it with the
regular pigs my point is nobody says the
phrase
i'm gonna go get some ham and cheese
pancakes nobody says i'm going to go get
a belgian waffle sandwich okay
what we're doing here is we're wasting
time arguing points that don't matter
what matters is that waffles are better
take it at polls pancakes are better
take it in polls let's see what we got
here let's see what we got
let's see what we've got here humble pie
type humble pie time i don't like this
anymore
you love it what do we got
sorry i believe that it's 51.49
i can't do this we have to wait another
couple of minutes too close to call
oh 50.9 percent
pancakes takes waffles at
point nine percent don't even say 51
say what it is point nine percent let it
sting the way it should
point nine percent that should show you
that
you have you're completely off the mark
i'm not off the mark
the goal isn't to be more on the mark
than not the goal is
to win the debate i won the debate i'm
right
pancakes won my food won let's see what
some comments are
and we'll keep checking in what is that
it's two feet with jelly on them it's
really gross
i gotta tell you look it's that's i'm
saying you're the peanut butter joey
roses is the jelly oh i see it's a
footwork peanut butter
let me tell you something right now let
me tell you something right now that's a
nice
what i mean
59 5149 you cannot you cannot begin to
gloat the way you're gloating
are you kidding i mean in in five
minutes
in five minutes this could be the other
way could
yes so don't gloat like that why and
also by the way i think this is a win
for me
because pancakes is way way more popular
pancakes are way more they were the
front runner they were the favorite to
come this close
under one percent nobody expected
it pancakes have been around since 1430
so to 1500 it's got nothing to do with
the way the show is structured
around 440 years
after the pancake and we are under a
percent
this guy dalton i i think dalton i guess
that's a man i can't see the picture i
don't know if that's a male or female
name but anyway dalton says
talk about speaking my language pancakes
unless they are eggo
waffles almost my exact
argument waffles with my heart on the
line
it all caps oh my god
someone just wrote option c
french toast no i know french toast
enters the chat
i know about french toast that would
have been a great three-way episode
pancakes waffles french toast
it would have been because i got news
for you we might rematch this i got news
for you
i think french toast is like a dark
horse here i really think french toast
is like
is i how did we not think of french
toast i thought of it throughout the
entire argument i just
decided not to bring it up no it's where
it's complicated enough already with
this oh i know what you thought
french crepe french toast a french toast
is just a pancake
no i did pop in my head a few times i
didn't want to complicate things because
it was like we were
you know that's not what we were
debating and and it couldn't support
either of our foods you know what i mean
this race is closer than biden and trump
waffles period
waffles hands down pancakes are too
fluffy not for me
depends uh fluffy blueberry pancakes for
breakfast but i do love good chicken and
waffles for dinner
wait go back i need 24 hours i need 24
hour prep if i'm going to have pancakes
in the morning
waffles are a little easier that's very
waffles are just pancakes with some
actual texture and contrast
agreed uh homemade waffles greater than
pancakes greater than frozen waffles
i'd honestly take a frozen waffle over a
fresh pancake
any day look you heard my argument about
frozen waffles i'll bang out a whole box
of eggos in one second here's someone
very reasonable
waffles are more reliable but pancakes
are better when done right
you're a person i can have a dialogue
with sir
okay well i i love how it's written to
just you like it's just you here talking
to yourself for an hour
just pointing out a point that resonated
with me you don't have to gloat even
more by the way if we refresh right now
i may be a winner
all right refresh if you refresh right
now maybe be a winner
oh my god it's lessening now it's point
seven percent
babe you hear the footsteps you hear
them i do you hear the footsteps dude
and pancakes was the front runner i know
you're getting down to a half of a
percentage
shame that we got it come on babe it's a
shame we got to end the episode
this is one of those this is i feel like
this is the stretch and it's like and
here comes waffles on the inside
i'll tell you what sal i bet you really
regret asking for that extra hour of
sleep right now because had we started
an hour earlier we wouldn't be so
pressed for time right now would we
and we have to end the episode folks
pancakes is the winner
who are you picking and who is our great
uh you got to give me something
i will give it to wait scroll down mike
i want to give it to this person right
here
because it's so close to what you said
i'ma just say it i hate pancakes i will
not eat pancakes it's like eating a
syrup covered sponge
that's so close to what you said we got
to give it to them that goes to
to ch chu shelly i think it's pronounced
at real moses tweets you can follow
shelly at real
moses tweets uh come by the joey rosa
sandwich shop 12 to four
wednesday to friday at the stand in new
york city uh joe rosa comedy on
instagram and twitter
yes that's it i love i hope you guys
have been enjoying the taste buds pod we
are
toying with the idea of doing a live
streaming episode on youtube where you
guys can have this uh
entire conversation with us in the
moment uh if so we will let you know
when that's gonna be
uh we think it's gonna be a blast so
it's something that we're really uh
looking forward to
what else just go to the youtube there's
no pressure network on youtube that's
our channel yeah we can find uh
hey babe the other podcast and uh yeah
we appreciate you guys
and we're having fun and uh if you like
this podcast too i always hear this too
and we never say it but like
if you like it the best thing that i
think you could do for us is to share it
and rate it right like
on any anywhere you're watching or
listening to it or whatever
you could share it and rate it subscribe
all those things
that really really really helps us
that's like the most immediate way if
you're a fan that you can show us
something like
reviews on itunes please yeah we're
trying to we're trying to build it up
we're having a blast doing this
uh no it doesn't sometimes it doesn't
look like it but it's fun we like we
like arguing this stuff it's great yeah
so thank you guys
uh am i forgetting anything no that's it
right on yeah we'll see you next time
do you still love me oh wait i forgot
i'm sorry yeah
i still love you oh my god waffles are
up by 0.1
50.1 to 49.9 oh my god
oh my god that's got a [ __ ] this is up
for debate this is gonna be a rematch
it's gotta be a rematch all right you
can't walk away with this with your head
held high
it's gotta be the favorite it's gotta
sting that the poles closed it's gotta
stink does it sting you
because you should also sting you oh i
walked away the victor i'll remember
you in your heart of hearts oh because
you know what the real winner is i'll
rematch you all day long you think cause
you
you think cause you maybe we do the
rematch live this is very good you think
cause you took a point one percent lead
that i'm going to be shaking in my boots
right now
i think you should be pleased i think i
think the tightest turn and you're
seeing
that the syrup is flowing toward the
waffle department i think that's rematch
right now you're i think right now
you're actually like actually you're
you're cloaking what you're really
feeling inside
which is your shook we've already agreed
that in a less than five percent um uh
margin we would consider rematch we're
rematching well this is i'm 100
into rematch but this is a 0.1 i know
it's that's this is what everyone
smiled i think all right well i
appreciate you waffle people you're
coming a little bit late to the party
but i appreciate it i'm going to go to
bed tonight feeling that waffles won
this i'm gonna go to bed tonight feeling
that the rematch
is gonna be taken by waffles uh i feel
good about uh what i put up
i still love you too taste buds they
coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs